هكذا هو الحال في قرى هذه الولايه الوادعه
يتنادى اهالي قريه بركات في محليه ام
روابه حاملين ادوات نضالهم المحببه الى
قلوبهم
الفاس والمكمك والسونكي
يشحدونها بشغف وحماس واستعداد منقطع
النظير لانطلاق موسم الطق وهي عمليه شبيهه
بعمليه تلقيح اشجار النخيل
ويصدف ان هذا هو دور اشجار العم حسين وهو
احد اعيان قريه بركات الذي تحدث لاهالي
قريته مرحبا بهم وشاكرا اياهم على وقوفهم
الى جانبه في هذا الموسم
موسم الحصاد السنوي يطاق الها شاب
هذه غابه قريه بركات وهي من الغابات
المنتجه للصمغ العربي
هناك اليه معينه لطج فروع هذه الاشجار فهي
لابد ان تكون في جهتين وليس في كل الجهات
والحكمه من ذلك ان يصل ضوء الشمس للفرع
الذي تعرض للتعريه من جهه الشرق والاتجاه
الذي يبقي ذلك الضوء حتى المغيب
المطر هو افضل غذاء لاشجار الهشاب المعطاء
وحراره الطقس سبب اخر لحماس هؤلاء
المنتجين المحليين اذ تعمل حراره الطقس
على استواء لحاء فروع الاشجار التي تتم
على مستواها عمليه الطج وهي عمليه نزع
اللحاء لافساح المجال للصمغ ليتدفق بعد ان
تكتمل عمليه التمثيل الضوئي
لكن لازم
اذا طقيت غيري